welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and Captain
America Civil War may arguably be the
most important film in the MCU this is
the movie that broke the Avengers and
the entry is filled to the brim with
incredible details Easter eggs and
tidbits that flesh out the entire
universe
I've been watched the Infinity Saga
countless times and with all of this
information stuffed in my head I'm here
to break down some of the best things
that you may have missed in the movie
the film actually gets a lot better with
the movies that follow it and there are
some crazy things that are set up here
that pay off in later entries obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to see Civil
War yet then I highly suggest that you
turn off now if you enjoy this breakdown
and be sure to leave a like and make
sure you subscribe to the channel to
never miss a video without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Captain America's Civil War
okay so the movie starts all the way
back in 1991 with Hydra forces calling
for the Winter Soldier this is to carry
out a mission that would have massive
repercussions on the Marvel Universe and
it sets off a chain of events that lead
to the collapse of the Avengers the
Easter eggs come thick and fast and the
code that the soldier we see at the
start enters is 1 7 8 to 6 if you look
at a telephone with letters on the
keypad one doesn't have any
however 7 8 2 6 all have corresponding
ones that spell out Stan which is a
notable nod to Stan Lee we then see the
Winter Soldier book which has the same
star in it that Bucky's arm does they
also wipe his mind using the exact same
machine from the Winter Soldier movie
that preceded this one in the Captain
America trilogy Bucky is fed words that
send him into a docile state and these
allow him to be controlled these words
include the numbers 1 9 and 17 which is
a reference to the other Bucky was born
1917 the word freight car is also used
and this could be a reference to his
apparent death in Captain America the
First Avenger homecoming is also one of
the trigger words that has given lip
service which is of course a nod to the
spider-man film of
same name and there are also some
amazing continuity details drop shortly
after all the way back in 2008 Zion man
we saw a newspaper chronicling the death
of Howard Stark that was dated the 17th
of December in 1991 in civil war we see
CCTV footage which is day at the 16th of
December 1991 showing that the stalks
were killed and their bodies were likely
found the next day in the report and
tower worldwide not long after we cut to
the Avengers mid-mission and this pretty
much kick starts the events that lead to
them going their separate ways
cast your mind back to age of Ultron and
you may remember a scene in which the
titular villain told Scarlet Witch that
she would be the one to tear the
Avengers apart
Ultron's words end up bringing true here
with Wonder becoming the catalyst that
drives a wedge between the group now bit
of trivia here in the introduction we
see a mercenary that holds the vial and
this is played by daemon Poitier this is
the same actor that played Danice in the
mid credit scene of the Avengers and
know he was eventually recast it's nice
that the actor got to come back even if
it was just for a minor part we can also
see an Avengers logo on caps uniform in
this introduction however when we catch
up to him later in the film at the
airport it's being completely removed so
he removes that when he leaves the
Avengers and later in the series when he
becomes the Nomad he removes the star on
his chest showing that he has stepped
down from being Captain America the
entire film centers around the notion
that you shouldn't compromise on your
beliefs this is exemplified in a speech
that Sharon Carter gives at Peggy's
funeral in which she recounts how her
aunt I told her to plant herself like a
tree and tell others to move this is
mirrored throughout the film with
several scenes in which a character
refuses to move when Black Panther comes
face to face with Black Widow his
bodyguard says move or you will be moved
Bucky asks Sam to move his seat up in
the car and Falcon says no ant-man
Stan's in Black Panthers way at the
airport and Black Widow also does this
it all culminates in cap trying to tell
a young man in the final battle at Hydra
had control over Bucky's mind
and Tony says move which ends up with
the two going head to head the theme of
breaking the Avengers up is also
metaphorically shown at several points
Tony takes a pair of vintage pens to
Steve in the hopes that he will finally
send the sokovia
cords FDR signed the lend-lease bill in
1941 with these and in some ways they
led to the creation of Captain America
Steve almost does it was so close he
almost does it but in the end he refuses
to sign now to me the two pens represent
Steve and Tony once they were together
but after he quote/unquote breaks of the
set aka the avengers steve places is
outside the box showing that they are
now apart steve placing the pen outside
the case represents him being outside
the box and operating beyond it the pen
that is in the box represents tony and
how he must now work within certain
confines because he signed the accords
it's an amazing scene especially when
you revisit it with this in mind and it
shows the level of subtext that goes
into their relationship after the
opening action scene in nigeria we cut
to tony stark's bath Prest at MIT and
far from home we learn that this was the
project headed up by Quentin Beck aka
Mysterio Mysterio remembered people
laughing at the acronym that Stark had
chosen for his technology however in
civil war the audience is silent
this shows that Quentin remembers it a
lot different to the reality of the
situation and signifies his ego led him
to become a maniac in this scene Tony
says I love you dad and I know you did
the best he could this sets up an
exchange in endgame when Tony gets to
see his father and when Howard asks him
about his dad stock jr. says he did his
best Tony tells the crowd to go break
some eggs and he runs into Miriam's
sharp she says if you have the money
break as many eggs as you like this
shows he is careless and now he's passed
it on to the world and must be held
accountable
Miriam sharp was in the original Civil
War comic book arc and she was pretty
much the face of the superhero
Registration Act shortly after we jumped
to Steve Rogers sitting watching the
news in his room he can actually see the
monkey that he sketched in the first
film when he was fed up of performing
the star-spangled man with a plan the
first time it appeared was to show how
he thought that people viewed him and in
the wake of the disaster it reappears
here to show that he wants more believes
that that is what the public think of
him at the Accords meeting we learn that
74 died during the Battle of New York
when vision is discussing the causality
between the rise of the Avengers and the
way that the world is turned rody says
boom which is a callback to the story
that he told an age of Ultron which also
ended the same way in age of Ultron
Rolly took down many versions of the
robot and because of this we can see
that he's painted his armor with Ultron
Sentinel heads cap gets a text that
Peggy has passed away and journeys to a
funeral the writers of the film confirm
recently that the old man we see
carrying Peggy Carter's casket is
actually old Steve Rogers depending on
what version of endgame timelines you
subscribe to whether it's the writers or
directors
this is either a cool little easter egg
or well it just doesn't make any sense
anyway passing that at the funeral we
learn that agent 13 it's actually the
niece of Peggy Carter
if you revisit the Winter Soldier you
will see a scene in which he hangs up
the phone and says to Steve that she was
calling her aunt she says she has
insomnia and insomnia appears in 1 & 4
people with dementia we learned in that
film that Peggy has dementia and
therefore there were some clues to set
this Ruby all up shortly after this the
bombing that kills King to chucker is
apparently carried out by Bucky we later
learn that he was framed using facial
prosthetics and we saw these used in the
Winter Soldier in which black were told
under disguise we later discover that
Zemo murder the doctor assigned to Bucky
and this was actually a cameo by
director Joe Russo who is pretty much
appeared in all of the movies that he's
been a part of Bucky is also placed in
holding cell D 23 which is a reference
to the Disney event that happens every
year in which they showcase their latest
movies and projects we see in the film
that Bucky is the first person to
understand a Jim and tonight as we learn
in the movie that the winter soldiers
can speak multiple languages civil war
is also about the friendship between
Bucky and Steve and how since the death
of Peggy Bucky is all that Steve has
from his past it really brings the film
together and there's a scene in which
they reminisce over their life Bucky
talks about a girl he once dated named
Dolores aka dot and this could be a
reference to the character from agent
Carter Dottie Underwood it's during this
time that Tony visits Peter Parker in
order to recruit him he waits with Mae
for Peter to return home from school and
when he does we can actually see that
Mae is wearing Ben's wedding ring around
him
this is clearly a tribute to the
character who we learn has died before
we ever got a chance to meet him in the
MCU Tony asks if Peeta has a passport
and in spider-man homecoming we see that
the day of Peters passport is May the
3rd 2016 this is actually three days
before the release of the film so it
looks like Tony pulled some strings in
order to get him to the airport now the
fight scene was pretty much analysed to
death on YouTube upon its release but
there's actually a lot of things that
happen in it that return in later movies
after becoming giant man and getting
tied up Scott asks if anyone has any
orange slices an Avengers end game after
Hawkeye returns from his first time
travel trip we can actually see Scott
trying to grab him some orange slices in
the background the battle ends with war
machine plummeting to earth and becoming
paralyzed because of it clearly Tony
feels a lot of guilt over this
especially because the film ends with
him helping his friend to learn to walk
again in order to stop this from
happening after the movie Tony builds a
parachute into spider-man's costume
Clint introduces himself by name and
T'Challa shoots him down saying that he
doesn't care
this pops back up in Avengers end game
when Black Panther actually acknowledges
him by name when the group run the
gauntlet
during the fight spider-man and cap come
face-to-face the webhead says that stark
told him to go for the legs and when
Tony and Steve fight later in the film
this is one of the first things that the
character does cap also does a spin in
pole to defeat Peter and Peter would
like to do this in homecoming showing
that he learned from his opponent when
war machine and Iron Man land at the
airport
the former shakes the camera and this
shows that his suit is much heavier than
stocks to chalalan silently due to his
shock-absorbent feet and he's later go
on to make his sneakers in the solo film
for the character Steven Bucky get away
and the other members of the group get
arrested and confined to the raft when
we see Scott in his cell later he can be
seen tapping away almost like a drumkit
later the character would come to spend
a lot of his time drumming when under
house arrest in ant-man in the wasp Tony
learns of caps true mission and what's
really going on and he sets off to meet
the pair now after the invention of
vision which pulled from Jarvis Tony
updated his AI to a female sounding
voice named Friday when asking if she's
run facial recognition on Zemo she says
what do I look
like Tony replies that he was thinking
of a redhead and know this could be a
reference to pepper potts it's actually
also a callback to the comics in which
Friday was a ginger Tony learns the
truth about his parents death and he
lunges for Bucky cabers able to hold him
back and this is because you can hear
that he doesn't have any hydraulics
powered on this is Tony moving the suit
on his own
powered by raw emotion during the fight
Tony uses the laser from Iron Man 2 that
he said he can only use once and this is
why it doesn't reappear later in the
fight
iron man also fights using the martial
arts form Wing Chun which we saw him
learning in Iron Man 3 the fight ends
with everyone feeling that they're lost
and Tony and cap go their separate ways
Tony says his father made the shield
which is a callback to Captain America
the First Avenger everyone sits around
contemplating the losses that they've
faced and we see vision thinking about
the events during this scene he is
holding a rook which is the only chess
piece that isn't a person this shows he
doesn't believe that he is truly human
rather just a weapon of war we get the
awesome Tony stank line from Stanley and
this chronologically lets us know that
the movie takes place before guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 is in that he talks
about the time he was a FedEx guy the
movie ends with Tony receiving a foam
from cap which would later appear in
infinity war though Tony refused to use
it in the post credit scene Peter says
that he was hit by Steve from Brooklyn
who was of course Captain America he
also says that his friend was huge which
is a nod to Giant Man anyway that's our
entire list and as always with the MCU I
had a hell of a lot of fun making this
video and I hope you enjoyed it too
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the tidbits so comment below and let
me know you want something else to watch
them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the insane details that we
noticed in Avengers infinity war as
there's some crazy details in there that
I haven't really seen anyone mentioned
before every month on the 15th we give
away free blu-rays and all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning the
Infinity Saga box set is comment below
leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button you can also come chat to us on a
discord server link below or a
definition whitey on Twitter
that's the best way to keep up to date
with the channel so hopefully we see
over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition
you've been the best now see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]